on the internet across more than four
Decades of incredible films please join
me in welcoming to summer game Fest
Nicholas Cage
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you everybody thank you happy to
meet you Nick I gotta say welcome to the
Video Game World oh wow yeah thank you
I'm so happy to be invited to your very
very cool Club everybody
finally I mean I gotta say this is such
a crazy unexpected collaboration I gotta
understand how did this come out I mean
some people be like oh maybe he'll show
up in Fortnight maybe he'll be in hideo
Kojima game but dead by daylight I mean
how does this happen well it's it's a
museum of horror right and when I make
movies one of my favorite genres is
horror and in this and and in that genre
there's a character a murderous ghost
named sadiko who I think is amazing and
she made an appearance in this game so
that was good enough for me okay yeah I
mean that's what's fun is you're playing
one of the survivors in this game and
it's cool that you know it's it really
is this Museum of horror Michael Myers
you said all these different characters
all coming together
um and you do you you play yourself or
who do you play so I play this uh
heightened exaggerated version of a film
actor named Nick Cage
he's uh he's going to a location
thinking he's making a movie and instead
he wakes up in the fog and in the fog
he's surrounded by crows and serial
killers and it's rather amusing and
there's something about it that I think
as a Survivor is like a bonding
experience it's a bit like hide and go
seek you have your three other teammates
who are survivors with you and it's
teamwork you're working together to pull
through and I like that and so that was
a large reason for wanting to do it as
well that that feeling of bonding with
your friends and you're fully Infamous I
know we heard your voice in there so you
recorded lines for it and everything see
I want you to know when you're playing
the Nick Cage Survivor I even have when
you're choosing your skins I even say
always remember to dress to match your
talent I want you to know that you're
with me that we're one that were fused
and so it was important to me that
everything I do everything I say from
the scream to the grunt down to the most
minimal exasperated expression of a AI
whatever it is it's my voice so that we
are fused all right
fully method the cage I love it I I mean
this is so fun this game as you said is
such an awesome kind of you know
collaboration with so many different
characters for you I mean how did you
find out about dead by daylight do you
know much about the video game somebody
very important in my family is a dead by
daylight Enthusiast and and that really
put the uh hook in pun intended uh
uh see dead by daylight to me was an
opportunity to Branch out to I've never
been invited into this space before I'm
always looking for new adventures so
this to me was like wow I can I make it
I can make a whole new audience meet a
whole new audience and Branch out and go
on this dead by daylight and Adventure I
didn't say it took me nothing but a
split second to say yes and speaking
about split seconds what excuse me what
I noticed excuse me sinuses uh allergies
what I noticed was that every move you
make when you're doing this when you're
in the gaming space it's it's time down
to the Split Second it's a very
immersive experience when you're acting
out in this space because every move
every grunt every saw you make has to be
timed perfectly with the gamers move so
that was something that I learned from
this and I'm always looking to learn
something well we love having you in the
video game where we want to see Nick
Cage in more games
[Applause]
Nicholas Cage great to see you man there
you go lock it in
now for all of you who want to play Nick
Cage in dead by daylight the chapter
officially comes out on July 25th on PC
and console but PC players can try it
earlier by downloading the player test
build on July 5th and here's an
exclusive first look at Nicholas Cage in
dead by daylight
[Applause]
damn right I made it